first case of covid re-infection has
been confirmed in the u.s
according to a study published by the
lancet medical journal the patient's
symptoms were far more severe
the second time round the 25 year old
man from nevada who has
no recorded immune disorder first tested
positive
in april he later recovered with two
negative tests
but in june developed severe symptoms
and again
tested positive it's the fifth case of
reinfection registered
worldwide and the second case where the
symptoms got worse
mark pandori the lead author of the
study says this shows
surviving coronavirus wants doesn't make
you immune
scientific data that we have from this
case and other cases would indicate that
if somebody has had covered 19 we just
don't know whether that person can be
reinfected
again it's possible that they could be
re-infected again but it's also
possible that some people are immune in
fact it could be that the vast majority
of people are immune
and it could be something else it could
be that our immune system gives us a
resistance that makes the second case
of a lesser but asymptomatic infection
despite the confirmed cases of
reinfection some people
seem to think they're immune among them
donald trump who has now recovered after
catching covid earlier this month
the u.s president has even since being
thrown seen
been seen throwing his mask into a crowd
of supporters
now they say i'm immune i can feel i
feel so powerful i'll
walk into that audience i'll walk in
there i'll kiss everyone in that
audience
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
women and um
everybody i'll just give you a big fat
kiss
[Applause]
mark pandori the lead author of the
study again says vaccination is the key
to immunity our only real hope of
achieving
herd immunity comes from vaccines
and vaccinology and this finding does
not speak to
vaccine-mediated immunity people that
have
been infected can't make the assumption
that they're immune because they've now
been
several cases that show that it isn't
true because you can be reinfected you
really have to be treated as if you were
never infected
and that's not only to protect you but
to protect others